the parents of a toddler who fell to her
death from an open cruise-ship window
are telling us why they filed a wrongful
death lawsuit against the cruise line
chloe weakens family blames royal
caribbean for failing to provide
reasonably safe children entertainment
areas including reasonably safe windows
the girl's grandfather Salmonella says
he lifted her to what he thought was a
closed window when she fell from his
arms he has now been charged with
negligent homicide or lead national
correspondent David bag no spoke with
her parents David good morning to you
how are they doing oh it's a hard week
especially this week gale in fact Chloe
would have turned two years old tomorrow
her mother Kim told us yesterday she
should be here already to celebrate with
cake and presents but instead she says
she spends every night at home sitting
by Chloe's urn one of the things that
disappoints me about all of it in losing
Chloe is that I think when you google
her name all you're gonna see is things
about court cases and people really
forget that this was all living
breathing human being part of our family
an actual person that's been lost there
will be people who watch this who say
and don't understand why they're suing
what would you say man played a major
role in our daughter's death and because
that condition shouldn't have existed
we've said that since the beginning
attorney Michael Winkelman is
representing the family in their lawsuit
against Royal Caribbean you believe the
death of Chloe was an accident yes but
then why sue the cruise line because
they could have and should have done
more to protect Chloe and to protect
other kids he argues that this specific
cruise ship freedom of the seas did not
comply with industry safety standards
including fall prevention window guards
and screens and a device that would have
limited the window opening to four
inches it's our clear allegation in the
complaint that they either knew about
these windows safety window fall
prevention codes or should have known
about them because it's the industry
standard if they would have solved
eighty codes mounted their ship all
their ships and then never would have
happened she'd still be here today we
want them to fix their cruise ship so
that no other kids get hurt
Chloe's grandfather Salmonella spoke
very briefly at the news conference
Wednesday they said here broken we all
sit here broken a lot of people have
reached out to me and said does the
family support Sam of course we do we've
always been a family we've continued is
fun to time together weekly we continue
to share dinners together it's just
tough she's my little girl
and she was the light of my life
anymore
in a statement to CBS News Royal
Caribbean says its hearts go out to the
family and that the company will have no
comment on the civil filing at this time
Chloe's grandfather is due back in court
next week in Puerto Rico Chloe's mother
who is a prosecutor herself says the
family never wanted charges to be filed
against mr. anello and I want to show
you guys a picture which may help clear
up some things this photo which is
included in the lawsuit lawsuit actually
shows the railing you see it there in
the bottom window has glass he has
maintained the whole time that Chloe was
beneath him and when he looked down what
he saw was glass so this makes it
plausible when you look at it that he
would have seen glass right because the
portion that was open was about chest
high where Chloe was there was glass
okay as a parent it's always tracked
with me what I've heard from that family
from the grandfather and also from the
parents I wish we heard more from world
carribean at this point but I understand
why they're being so excite we've tried
so hard to clear up any miscommunication
let us know and they just they will
eventually have that say something I'm
so glad though the family keeps saying
we're standing by salmonella at this
they've not wavered thank you David